[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
my hero academia video our last video
about the top 10 weakest quirks in my
hero academia receives a huge response
way bigger than we were expecting
some of you agreed with our choices some
of you didn't but that's perfectly fine
of course since not only does everyone
have their own opinion but we still
don't even know a lot about some of
these quirks in the first place so we
don't know for sure what the true
potential of these quirks is one thing
we do know is that we received a massive
number of requests for a top 10
strongest quirks video so we felt we
have to deliver on this one and if you
want to discuss the best and worst works
in greater detail you can join our
discord server link in the description
if you enjoy our might hero academia
videos and you want to see more be sure
to Texas smash that like button shout
out to Texas and if you are new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell before we
begin it is important to note that for
this list we will be looking at quirks
with the strongest combat capability and
destructive potential rather than quirks
that are really useful in other ways
such as recovery girls quirk for example
also we will mostly be looking at the
quirk itself rather than the user some
users may not have the greatest work but
with their own incredible skill they are
able to make their work much more
powerful than it would have been in the
hands of anyone else and hero killers
stain is a perfect example of that
fames quirk is actually pretty hard to
activate not only does he have to make
contact with his opponent but he also
has to draw his blood and lick it and
yes stain became one of the most deadly
fighter in this series because of his
incredible skill and dedication finally
just because a quirk doesn't appear on
this list doesn't mean that we don't
think it's powerful we just think that
these are the 10 most powerful and these
based on all the information we have so
far after all we still don't even know
who the number three ranked pro hero is
so there is of course a lot more than we
need to learn about the world
my hero academia and as we do learn more
we will be happy to post an updated
video and now that we've got all this
established let's get into it just a
quick warning there will be manga
spoilers as some of the quirks and
characters in this list haven't even
been introduced in the anime yet so
proceed with caution at number 10 we
have fold a body fold the body is a
transformation type quirk that allows
the user to fold and stretch his body
giving him incredible strength and
agility the user of this quirk is ed
shock the number five ranked pro hero
this quirk is similar to another quirk
in the mind hero academia world called
fly a body which is possessed by the pro
hero tiger however both the body is much
stronger because each shot is capable of
transforming his body faster than the
speed of sound and he uses this immense
speed to turn his quirk into a powerful
offensive weapon he can even twist and
turn his body into a sharp weapon and
then use it against his opponents head
shot demonstrated the impressive power
of his quirk during the hideout raid art
when he knocked Kuno giddy unconscious
before anyone else even noticed what was
happening it is no wonder that an shock
made it into the top five strongest pro
heroes with this powerful work but the
quirk itself is not the only reason
ed shot is so strong headshot is a good
example of someone who improved upon an
already strong quirk with rigorous
training so even though the quirk is
strong on its own it is made yet more
powerful as a result of his discipline
and determination for this reason we
have to include this quirk in our top 10
strongest at number nine dragon form
well the exact name of this quirk is
unknown but I'm just going to call it
dragon form in this video this quirk is
possessed by a roo cube the number nine
ranked pro hero and it allows her to
transform into an actual dragon even
though we still don't know too much
about her quirks we do know that in her
dragon form a trio pew becomes massive
in size and extremely powerful she is
able to deal with very strong villains
on her own and without much trouble she
also has wings in her dragon form so we
can
assume that she can fly which would be
an extremely useful ability in combat
the only reason that this quirk does not
rank higher on our list is that we don't
know enough about it for example we
don't know if it has any major
limitations like real Q being able to
use it only for a few minutes at a time
or something along those lines as we
learn more about this quirk it is
possible that it will move up higher on
the list and be featured in an updated
video sometime in the future AB number
eight we have dict a formerly known as
disintegration before its english name
was confirmed to be decay this quirk is
possessed by Tamora shigaraki the acting
leader of the league of villains this is
an emitter type work that works on
contact and it has the power to
literally disintegrate anything that
Shigure Aki lays his hands on the
destruction activates automatically
whenever he touches something with all
five of his fingers so in order to touch
anything that he doesn't want to destroy
shigaraki has to make sure that he
touches it with only a part of his hand
there is no question that this is an
immensely powerful quirk not only can it
disintegrate a human body but also much
stronger materials like stone and metal
the reason the Kay doesn't rank even
higher on our list is that it does have
a few drawbacks for one thing she karate
has to make physical contact with
whatever he wants to destroy and he
cannot control the quirk completely so
anything he touches with all five
fingers will disintegrate even if he
doesn't want it to the other thing is
that it appears to take some time for
his quirk to work although there are
various interpretations about how long
it actually takes shigaraki to
disintegrate something we saw that
during his fight with Eraserhead at the
usj he was able to injure Eraserhead arm
but not disintegrated completely before
Eraserhead punched him and forced him to
back off also while fighting against
stain it takes a little while for
shigaraki to disintegrate the blade that
state is holding so this appears to
suggest that most of the time this quirk
will need to maintain contact for at
least a few seconds in order to work
properly and of course this can be a
serious drawback against the best
opponent in a quick moving battle at
number 7 we have overhaul
overall is the name of the quark
possessed by chisaki a member of the
yakuza whose villa name also happens to
be overhaul this powerful quirk allows
over how to disassemble anything he
touches producing a similar effect to
that of sugar akin to the cake work with
some important differences overhaul does
not need to touch his target with his
entire hand only a finger is enough and
it appears to work instantaneously he
has some control over how much is
actually disassembled and if he chooses
not to kill someone but merely
disassembled parts of their body he can
then reassemble them again and all of
the past injuries and illnesses within
the body will have been cured like
shigaraki overhaul appears incapable of
simply turning the quark off so he wears
special gloves that allow him to keep
his power in check another drawback is
that using his quirk appears to take a
physical toll on overhaul it leads in to
develop a rash and itching but
nevertheless this incredibly powerful
work that not only disassembles but can
also reassemble people and objects
definitely deserves to be at number 7
number 6
explosion no not that one the other guy
yeah yeah that's it explosion is the
name of the quark possessed by class 1a
student kotsky baku go and this work
allows its user to create powerful
explosions out of the sweat that is
excreted from the palms of their hands
instead of normal sweat bottle produces
a highly explosive liquid similar to
nitroglycerin and he is able to use it
to create explosion Baku can then use
these explosions both as an offensive
weapon and as a way to propel himself
into the air this is an extremely
powerful and versatile quirk and even
though Baku is still just a student
he is already able to use his quirk to
effectively battle both villains and
fellow students thanks to his quirk he
was the winner of the final event of the
you a Sports Festival the battle
tournament although show totally rocky
but Google's opponent in the finals
refused to use its full power during the
battle there are some drawbacks to this
work such as the fact that it is harder
to use in a cold environment because it
requires sweat to work properly however
this is one of the quirks with the
most potential in my opinion and the
incredibly quick progress that possible
makes in mastering and improving his
quirk demonstrates its strength and
versatility at number five black hole
black hole is at work used by the space
hero 13 whose gender by the way has not
been confirmed so all of you guys
commenting that 13 is a girl it's not
confirmed he could be a girl or a guy we
don't know yet this quirk enables its
user to generate small black holes that
can suck it and disintegrate both matter
and light on an atomic level which means
that this quirk has utterly devastating
destructive potential black hole is so
powerful that it can be hard to control
and is therefore very dangerous it can
suck up and destroy anything in its path
including objects human beings and even
pure energy such as light 13 uses the
quirk primarily for getting rid of
hazardous debris during rescue mission
but if a quirk is this powerful ever
fell into the wrong hands it could wreak
unprecedented havoc on entire cities and
perhaps even beyond that depending on
what the limitations of this quirk
actually are the immense power of this
quirk is undeniable but the fact that it
is so difficult to control is the reason
that it doesn't rank even higher on our
list black hole can also backfire on its
own user as was demonstrated when Kudo
Geary uses core warp gates to turn black
hole back on its own user at the usj for
these reasons black hole finds itself at
number 5 number 4 hell flame hell flame
is the name of the fire based work used
by the number two ranked Pro Nero and
ever the fact that endeavor is the
second most powerful Pro hero is no
coincidence
his emitter type medium range quirk is
one of the strongest works in the world
of my hero academia hell flame allows
its user to generate and manipulate
extremely powerful flames which makes
for a devastatingly effective offensive
weapon the user can create fireballs
Spears and other objects made out of
fire and endeavor was even seen using a
squirt to climb walls by melting certain
points on the wall by focusing heat to
the soles of his feet allowing him to
stick to the wall
in addition the heat produced by the
square can be increased to such an
extent that the flames turned blue and
when they are this hot the flames can
destroy their target on a cellular level
preventing any form of regeneration from
taking place another huge benefit of the
square is that it can be reactivated
when the user wants to do so the user
does not have to worry about constantly
burning everything around him despite
the fact that endeavour as a person has
many flaws his quirk is without a doubt
one of the strongest in my hero academia
number three has cold hot hot hot cold
hot hot is a quirk possessed by shuttle
Todoroki the son of the number two
ranked pro hero and ever like his father
Todoroki can generate powerful flames
from his body from the left side of his
body to be specific
from the right side of his body Todoroki
is able to generate ice and he can use
it to freeze objects and people around
him and he inherited the ability to
generate ice from his mother who has an
ice based quirk Todoroki can even create
giant walls of ice and freeze entire
buildings the one drawback of this quirk
is that if he uses either side too much
Todoroki can suffer physical
consequences either frostbite from its
cold side or potentially dehydration and
exhaustion from his hot time however if
he uses both sides of his work in a
complementary way he can largely
counterbalance the negative effects of
one side with the other for this reason
half cold hot hot is one of the
strongest and most versatile quirks in
male hero academia
not only does Todoroki possess the flame
based powers of his father but he also
has the ice based power that he
inherited from his mother and this adds
a lot more versatility to his quirk an
effective combination of the two powers
has the potential to take down even the
fiercest opponent as endeavour himself
predicted all along has cold hot hot has
the potential to overtake the power of
hell flame and perhaps one day become
the most powerful quirk in all of my
near academia once
Todoroki is able to master it fully but
until that day it will remain
at number three before we get to the top
two quirks I want to give a few
honorable mentions including mount lady
squirt jug identification which allows
her to grow to an incredible size and of
course to gain incredible physical power
however she is limited in confined
spaces search where it cannot be used in
confined spaces which is a weakness of
her word also we have chrono stasis one
of the new eight precepts of death his
work appears to be able to either slow
down time or someone's perception of
time like Rolo's Geass and Code Geass
which sounds pretty badass in this
theory about the quirk is accurate we
also have to mention kou aki-nee and his
powerful quark warp gate however he has
to use his quirk to trick his opponents
rather than take them head-on so he has
to trick them in order to turn their own
works on themselves or to transport them
somewhere else so for that reason he is
not on this list we also have the perk
used by the number 10 the ranked pro
hero gang Orca which gives them the
power of a killer whale however because
if you use the number ninth ranked pro
hero ranks higher and also her quirk
turns her into a dragon we had to leave
gang Orca off this list we can't forget
gran torino who's quark jet gives him
the ability to jump high and move really
fast which also allows him to hit very
hard however we don't know how much risk
work is actually the quark and how much
is his own skill and ability I said to
think that Gran Torino is more powerful
because of its skill than just because
of his quirk and also his quirk is
limited by how much air he can inhale so
in cases where he would be sick or
injured and couldn't take a deep breath
that would be a big limitation to his
work finally we have to mention vest
genus with quark gifts and the ability
to control the fibers in clothes and he
uses us very effectively to fight
against opponent while this is a great
quirk when clothing is present it will
not be effective at all on a nudist
beach and also that anyone else noticed
that Momo from class 1-a
appears to be his kryptonite the more
clothing someone is wearing the easier
it is for fest genus to use his quirk
however the less clothing Momo has on
the easier it is for her to use her
creation quirk and of course if you want
to learn more about the pro heroes the
villains and
one A and one B and all of their quirks
you can check out our videos on these
topics links are in the description and
now at number two we have all four one
not to be confused with one for all all
for one is at work used by the
mastermind behind the legal villain a
man who also goes by the name hole for
one all for one allows its user to steal
the quirks of others and then use those
quirks himself including combining
multiple works at once to create
incredibly destructive attacks if total
Rocky's quirk is powerful because it
combines two different powers then
imagine all for one as a cleric that
allows you to combine an even larger
number of quirks and use them all at the
same time this in itself sounds pretty
incredible but on top of that all-4-one
also allows its user to transfer stolen
works on to other people some of the
unfortunate individuals who have their
quirks stolen by all-4-one are left in a
vegetative state similar to a coma and
some people who receive a stolen quirk
as a result of all-4-one are unable to
handle them and they themselves become
mindless creatures capable of nothing
but following orders just like the
normal and if that wasn't enough the
user of over 1 can combine multiple
stolen works in one person in order to
create more powerful super quirks that
would never have occurred naturally and
in Chapter 90 we learned that all for
one can even forcibly activate the
quirks of others for these reasons I
think that over one is probably the most
dangerous work in the entire world for
my hero academia imagine using it to
create armies of super soldiers with
artificially engineered quirks which are
more powerful than any naturally
occurring quirk could ever be
I was really debating about putting over
one as the strongest quirk in my hero
academia and for a long time it was the
most powerful one but based on
everything that happens in the manga we
now know that there is one quirk that is
currently more powerful and that number
one we have one for all one for all is a
very interesting quirk because it
combines two separate works at work that
stockpiles
our and a quirk that allows first to be
transferred from one person to another
as a result of the ability to stockpile
power one for all gives its users
superhuman strength reflexes stamina
agility and speed
once the quirk is transferred from one
person to another the one who transfers
it can still make use of some leftover
embers which is why Oh Mike is still
able to use this power even after
transferring one for all onto deku
however these embers will eventually run
out the true workings of one parole are
still a mystery such as in the situation
where dec was able to break through the
control of his efficient so squirt
during the tournament arc it appears
that the previous users of one-for-all
were somehow able to awaken inside that
group and bring him back to his senses
it also appears that one for all becomes
more powerful as it is passed on from
one person to another which would make
sense since the cleric stockpiles power
so the more people use it the more power
is stockpiled we know that none of the
seven users of one for all prior to all
might could defeat all for one but once
all might get the power he is able to
defeat over one on two separate
occasions it is for this reason that I
believe that one for all is currently
more powerful than all for one as all
Mike was able to defeat over one white
one for all does have its drawbacks such
as the fact that until the quirk is
mastered it will cause serious damage to
the user's body but all Mike's power and
strength demonstrates that once the
quirk is mastered it becomes virtually
unrivaled in the world of my hero
academia also almighty tells us that to
activate one for all the user must
clench their buttocks and scream smash
within their heart which is probably the
best way to activate a quirk ever and
that is it everybody our top 10
strongest works in my hero academia this
is just our opinion of course based on
our knowledge of the manga anime and
additional material such as the
character guidebook but please feel free
to tell us what your picks are down in
the comments below we always love to
hear your thoughts and our goal is not
to tell you what we think is the only
right answer
but rather to start on interesting
conversation and if you want to discuss
the best and worst works in greater
detail you can join our discord server
link in the description if you enjoyed
this video be sure to text us smash that
like button and if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell as always
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]